hey guys what's up welcome to amsterdam
my name is timon diaz and i'm an editor
for hain style which is the largest
dutch weblog
in the world today i'm once again joined
by a man who no longer needs any
introduction dr jordan peterson how are
you doing thanks for sitting down with
us again
nice to see you again
uh the last time we sat down for a talk
in our studio in two weeks that will be
exactly one year ago
and then what else um it was the first
time you responded on video to the
aftermath of the of the kathy newman
interview and we also did a discussion
of my distillation into five points of
your philosophy
uh for the people at home for the people
watching you can find the link in the
description if you wanna if you want to
check it out today i again want to do
five things and i'm going to run through
them before we start
we're going to do a year review of 2018
in which i just want to hear how you
look back on last year what you've been
through what what uh what were the
defining experiences
um then we're going to discuss how in
identity politics a collective narrative
substitutes the individual experience
and then we're going to leave the
physical world and go metaphysical we're
going to discuss the movie gladiator and
why it is so ingrained in
my generation psyche more so than any
other movie of its sort
and then we're going to discuss how to
become sorry how to become something
approximating the male archetype and
we're going to focus especially on the
union notion of individuation we're
going to really delve into that
and five and final point
we're going to discuss the idea it's a
union idea that the artist is a portal
between the dream world and the
collective unconscious on one hand
and consciousness on the other hand i
wonder if we should reverse the order of
the fourth and the fifth
so start with art and then
individuation all right i can do that
note it yeah i think that'll make a
better narrative flow all right we'll do
that okay
well without further ado let's delve
into it
year review i've always wanted to do
that i'm sorry
what were your what were the defining
experiences for you how do you look back
on it you visited over 100 cities
one on i can't even name 100 cities so
that's impressive
well i did visit a couple of them twice
so but i think it was 115 lectures and
so
sums to 100 cities yeah
the defining features of it well
back in january
that's when my book came out and it was
at that point that i started to
thoroughly realize that
there was enough of a market for what it
was that i was talking about to
risk
experimenting with
large-scale venues
and i i found that out
because of my experience two experiences
the year before i had done a series of
biblical lectures on genesis
and
i rented a theater in toronto more out
of curiosity than uh good sense let's
say
to see
if there might be an audience for such a
thing and the theater held about 500
people and
i did 15 lectures over the course of a
couple of months and
every
it sold out every time yeah
and so that
well that was you might call that a data
point
it was interesting because it wasn't
obvious that
a discussion of something as arcane and
archaic
and hypothetically outdated
as
the book of genesis would draw an
audience and the audience was also
primarily
composed of the people who you would
think least likely to come and attend
such a thing and that was
mostly men
and they healed you like a rock star
it was like
loud applause when you entered stage
yeah well i guess it's such a strange
thing to see actually that's for sure
especially in the context of the
discussions you know yeah and
so
so then
well then i went to london i think i've
got the
itinerary
the timeline correct
i might have mixed up might mix up a
couple of things but
i went to london
to talk about the launch of my book
because it was published there first and
i think it was published on january 23rd
so that's almost a year
behind
us now as well
yeah and
the publishers there wanted to arrange a
public talk
and so they first rented that 300 seat
auditorium theater and it sold out
instantly and so they moved it to a
thousand seats if i remember correctly
and then to a very large venue
of the apollo
i think that was in january although as
i said i'm not exactly certain
that might have followed my
yeah i think that's right
so
so that was
extremely interesting as well and that
went very well
and uh
my
after i came back from london
my daughter and i
decided to
try to do the same thing in l.a
at the uh
orpheum so we contacted them and of
course they were very skeptical and they
had every right to be because
they didn't know who i was and i wasn't
represented by any organization
the orpheum sold out too these are all
theaters of about 2500
capacity so they're fairly large scale
well
at the same time
around the same time interestingly
enough i was contacted by an
organization in l.a called caa creative
artists agency
it's the largest um it's the largest
agency of its type and i suppose the
most prestigious
um i was negotiating with another one at
the same time
or as an alternative but they contacted
me more or less out of the blue and said
that they would like to represent me and
they were associated with live nation
which does
theatrical bookings for performers of
all sorts all over the world
and so things just fell into place
yeah interestingly enough
my daughter michaela pushed very hard
for my uh
my enrollment with caa she thought after
multiple conversations with them that
they were very competent which they have
turned out to be
so
things just started to roll from there
and
we
we hit major
cities the major markets first in the
united states
and that went very successfully and so
uh we extended that to canada and then
into
smaller markets less
of 115
lectures i think about 100 of them sold
out completely the other ones did well
sometimes those were in markets that i'd
returned to
you know a few months previously
so
so those are highlights i mean
the highlight though really is the fact
that
the
lecture series has been so
positive
you know the the events are unbelievably
they're not political i wouldn't say
they're fundamentally psychological
[Music]
they concentrate on individual
development i speak about politics from
time to time but more from a
psychological perspective outlining
the temperamental reasons why people
might lean to the left or lead to the
right and emphasizing the necessity of
both perspectives let's say and and the
what meta necessity of them engaging in
continual dialogue in order to keep the
ship of state sailing
sailing upright and and and oriented
towards the proper destination let's say
so
what else well at the same time
you know there was still a tremendous
amount of media attention
uh often
negative sometimes positive
[Music]
a lot of contentious interviews with
journalists
uh interestingly enough
the more contentious
interviews like the kathy newman
interview but more recently an interview
i did with gq yeah um
tend to attract the most attention on
youtube um yeah though they're also the
most stressful and difficult of
interviews and
something that for the sake of my own
psychological stability should probably
be
somewhat avoided yeah it takes me about
three days to recover from an interview
like that yeah
and then also the overwhelming success
of the book which has now been
we have contracts in place to translate
12 rules for life into 50 languages
which pretty much does in all the
languages where there's a reasonable
publication market and
um it's sold two and a half million
copies in in hardcover and trade
paperback primarily hardcover that also
includes ebooks and kindle downloads and
that sort of thing in the english
language world and maybe another half a
million
in
the
countries where translations have
appeared on the end of those so far i
would say
so there's a huge market for
unpacking old stories
well apparently there's a market and
there's a huge market more importantly i
would say for
a discussion
that centers on the relationship between
responsibility and meaning which is also
something that i'm working on
delineating in my next book which i'm
busy writing right now in fact i was
writing it just writing a central
chapter chapter 6 which is called
notice that opportunity lurks where
responsibility has been abandoned
and one of the things i've noticed in
the lectures is that
whenever i talk about the relationship
between responsibility and meaning
the lecture
hall always goes dead silent and that's
very significant especially because it's
happened more than a hundred times and i
really be watching this so so i mean
that most specifically that
there's a
void in our culture
i think produced by non-stop discussion
of rights and privileges
and that void has to do with the
necessity for the counter-balancing
discussion which is a discussion of
responsibility and potency
the thing is is that conservative people
tend to
market
responsibility as duty right sort of as
should or should not
often should not
sometimes should
and
that's perfectly reasonable because we
have duties and they're necessary
because we're social creatures and we
have to engage in reciprocal
interactions with others but
it still misses the point
a point which is also missed by people
on the left who are always i would say
clamoring about rights and
who are
anti-hierarchical in their fundamental
orientation
most of the sustaining meaning that
people find in their lives is a
consequence of them
adopting responsibility
and
and that's that's something that's very
much worth deeply considering
do you think the the audience goes
silent because somehow it's encoded into
their psyche that if they adopt
responsibility something good happens to
them
well they know yeah they definitely know
but they haven't heard it articulated
sufficiently you know there's two things
that people usually tell me
when they come up to me which is another
thing that's happened a lot in the last
year like i was just out yesterday
walked down to the gym with my wife
which is about
five blocks away or someone
i was probably stopped by
people or so on the street in a 15
minute
period of time you know and
and
that happens pretty much wherever i go
now
i can imagine regardless of the country
which is also extremely interesting and
a testament to the insane reach of
let's say youtube and podcasts
um
people always tell me one of two things
you know they they say that
they've been listening to my
youtube lectures or watching them or
the podcast or reading the book and that
that's been useful to them in terms of
finding direction and purpose
and and affirmation even though that's a
word that should be used very cautiously
now because it's sort of being mouthed
to death
strength let's say an encouragement
those are better words
or they tell me that
they found words to describe things they
always knew to be true but didn't know
how to say this is also extremely useful
for people and perhaps the fundamental
purpose of intellectual uh adventure and
discourse on the humanities end of the
distribution right to articulate
truth
ancient truths and to bring it up to
date yeah that's very useful for people
and you see i kind of kind of lay out a
fairly standard argument in some sense
in the lectures
the first
that's a set of propositions and i try
to make them
invaluable in some sense propositions
that no one would disagree with
the first is that
life is very difficult and rafe was
suffering and contaminated by
malevolence at every level there's
natural malevolence
that's the proclivity of nature to try
to kill you and there's social
malevolence and individual malevolence
and
um
that
worsens the essential tragedy of life
and so the fundamental truth as
the religious types have always happened
is that life is suffering and the
consequence of that is that
you need a sustaining meaning to
to help you
avoid bitterness
yeah and then the question is where is
that sustaining meaning to be found if
it can be found at all and the answer to
that seems to be not in rights and
privileges and impulsive freedom and
instantaneous gratification not in any
of that but in the adoption of
responsibility for the appalling
conditions of the world at all of those
levels and then the determination to do
something about that
and i do believe that
people as soon as you tell people that
they understand it
and it's partly because
they
i i speak to people about who they
spontaneously admire
because admiration is uh
as the instinct for imitation let's say
that is one of the themes in gladiator
by the way
yes definitely definitely well it's one
of the it's one of the themes of
leadership per se right i mean
hypothetically a leader is someone
admirable and someone admirable is
someone that you follow and to follow is
to imitate all of those things and to
imitate is to practice a mode of being
so that you can undertake that mode of
being autonomously yeah
so if you look at
who or what you spontaneously admire you
could get some sense of
what constitutes
that which is of value and it's
inevitably i believe inevitably that
the people who are admired are people
who take responsibility and the more
responsibility that they take the more
admirable they become and so i don't see
how any of that is
is disputable in some fundamental sense
let's develop this thought further when
we get to gladia i think that's a good
that's a good point um
what i wanted to ask you you were quite
recently actually you were at a
breitbart event in turning point usa and
i want to just ask you a straight
question about that yeah were you are
were you comfortable there
well it wasn't a breitbart event it was
a turning point usa event and i was
interviewed there by breitbart but i
thought it was i thought it was a dual
event it had both breitbart and turning
point on the
on the posters i thought oh well that
look that could be that could be uh it's
not an indictment but i just yeah no
that's okay that's okay what was i
comfortable there well yes no i mean
no
uh
i find american political events
like i tend to view them to some degree
from the perspective of an
anthropologist the american political
scene is very very different than the
canadian purpose
like there's an evangelical element to
the american political scene that's
completely absent in canadian politics
[Music]
kind of a circus element and i'm not
being critical like there's there's some
real enthusiasm there but but you could
really see like a protestant revivalism
that characterizes american political
discourse and i've seen that many
of the larger scale american political
spectacles that i'd be peripherally or
centrally involved in so that's strange
to me and and interesting but i wouldn't
say it's a it's a situation that i feel
particularly comfortable in
um i don't have any objection to
speaking at such events because
i think that
whether or not i should speak at such
events is dependent to a large degree on
what it is that i'm speaking about
and i've spoken twice to the turning
point people and i've outlined
well a lot of the themes that i just
outlined with you and you know i've
encouraged them to
act responsibly which i think is a
message that conservatives have that's
saleable to young people in a way that
it it hasn't been for maybe three
generations yes i understand so
also i'm not saying that they're bad
people you shouldn't per se should not
be associating with the thing is mostly
that
those events are so ideologically hyper
charged yep and that's
yeah that's i kind of hope that my
participation serves as a uh
as a balance to that you know as
something that brings it back down to
earth because i'm not talking to them as
conservative party activists let's say
i'm talking to them as individuals
because i always talk to people as
individuals and
um
i i i also at both turning point events
that i've attended i attempted to lay
out the rationale for the left of center
viewpoint and to explain why that also
has to be taken into account yeah it's a
strange thing in some sense but they
invite me because
um i'm not
a partisan person
in any in any fundamental sense i've
also been working quite extensively with
the democrats
in one
manner in the us as well trying to
help a group of people who are
attempting to pull the central party
narrative away from the radical leftists
yeah
so when it comes to party politics your
main thesis that i always hear from you
is that
um the openness of say the left and the
particularly for order of the right have
to keep each other in balance yes that's
exactly it and well and the dialogue has
to continue right that's the fundamental
issue is that you you you want to ensure
that neither proclivity becomes so
polarized
or both
so that the dialogue ceases because then
you have well then you have something
approximating
well if not war then at least conflict
or repression or
right
so yes
you don't you have to watch the extremes
and you have to keep the dialogue going
however that can be managed
i think this is a good point to
transition to the the identity politics
chapter of our talk
so what i want to discuss is
well it's narrative substitution
and this kind of i came up with it
myself i don't know it makes any sense
but it sounds impressive and that's good
enough for me
so what i kind of mean by this eric
weinstein last september with dave rubin
he inserted that the concept of safe
spaces
don't serve to protect individuals they
serve to protect narratives that cannot
survive scrutiny from the outside world
so i've tried to develop this this
thought a little further and i came up
with the following thought that i want
to present you
um
in identity politics people's actual
individual experience is replaced by the
embodiment of a narrative of collective
oppression
which doesn't necessarily reflect their
actual position in society so in short
they're not as suppressed as the
narrative they subscribe to big states
you actually the data the data on that
from this psychological literature is
quite clear
if you
if you survey
minority group members let's say
um
they almost inevitably state that the
amount of oppression suffered by their
group far exceeds the oppression they
experienced as individuals
it's a very common finding yeah so so
how do we
how do you cope with this
very grave disparity between data and
narrative and narrative embodiment by
individuals even though it doesn't
reflect their actual
position in society
well let's go back a couple of steps to
your original propositions you said that
weinstein's comments for example were
that the purpose of safe spaces wasn't
to protect individuals but to protect a
narrative that can't bear scrutiny i
certainly believe that because when this
is something i hope to do in the next
year i've been looking into some of the
fundamental propositions of the identity
politics end of the political spectrum
the idea of the patriarchy the idea of
intersectionality
the idea that
what would you call it performance
increments can be
accrued as a consequence of
diversification of viewpoints along the
standard identity politics lines
those ideas are
intellectually weak almost beyond
comprehension yeah on the only and i i i
looked up um i think it was kate millet
my my memory might be failing me
i look i looked up
the
research let's call it on the idea of
white privilege on
the idea of the patriarchy and the idea
of intersectionality and i went and
tracked down the people who formulated
the ideas and started to look seriously
at what they had
written and discussed and
frankly it's
appallingly
intellectually weak
and i think the only reason it survived
at all is because so it was all
formulated in the universities the idea
of white privilege for example was
formulated at wellesley and the idea of
intersectionality at the law school at
ucla
and
i think the only reason that these ideas
have gained currency is because the
serious scholars in universities and
those would mostly but not all be those
who are pursuing
uh research in the stem disciplines
because of the fundamental corruption of
the humanities and much of the social
sciences have just ignored them
they haven't been subject to genuine
criticism hypothetically they're peer
reviewed but they're peer reviewed by
people who've already
taken the poison let's say or who are
possessed by the same set of ideas
as soon as you analyze those ideas they
fall apart so other disciplines other
academic disciplines have plainly
ignored this yeah well i think it's
because they never thought that the
ideas were worthy of
criticism right which is a real
criticism your ideas aren't even worthy
of criticism we're going to ignore them
and the problem the problem is that's
actually not worked out very well
because
well the stem types let's say we're busy
peering through their microscopes the
activist types were busy
corrupting the entire structure of the
university and and then spreading that
that
pathology of appallingly bad ideas out
into the broader culture
like the idea of intersectionality we
one of our focus on that it's like we
could just take that apart for a bit so
first of all
to be an intersectional
intersectionalist if that's a word
means that you have to buy the
oppression narrative you have to buy the
narrative that
history is the battleground between the
oppressed and the oppressors that's the
first thing so that's a quasi-marxist
presumption derived from
i would say it's an analog of the
proletariat bourgeoisie struggle that
was outlined as fundamentally by marx so
it's a variant of that i don't think
there's any doubt about that
do you have to buy that and i don't i
think it's an appalling appallingly
one-sided idea even though there is
oppression
um and that characterizes all social
institutions
um but that's by no means all the story
then you have to buy the idea that
the oppression actually occurs along the
canonical lines drawn
identity lines drawn by the identity
politics type so that would be
essentially
let's say race
ethnicity sexuality and gender
as canonical uh categories and i i don't
think the evidence for that is
overwhelming as well
and then having accepted those
propositions
unquestionably
then you notice that
oppression is more than one-dimensional
say well if you're black and female then
your oppression is either the sum or the
product of those two
minority statuses
i don't find that a particularly
compelling or original idea i think it's
obvious
and it's also self contradictory
and it's easy to think that through
because
as you multiply the number of
identity
axes along which you can be oppressed
you reduce the number of people in each
superordinate category
and my suspicions are that
you could figure this out
arithmetically with a bit of work
approximately at least
imagine that each person can be placed
into ten identity categories which i
don't think is unreasonable actually the
number of categories is the limit is
limitless
you end up with no groups you end up
right back to the individual and so
so which is essentially what the west
discovered i would say in its in some
basic form
some multiple thousands of years ago
so if you really want to take
everybody's differences into account
which is what the intersection was
claimed you should be doing then what
you end up doing is responding to each
person as if they're a unique individual
so and that's just one example of how
unbelievably shallow
these ideas are and how how easily
they're subject to what i would say
devastating criticism and that does
support science contention
yeah but i do think that what is often
overlooked because they're it's so
dominant in our um the way our
perception is shaped what is often
overlooked that actually very few people
subscribe to identity politics i think
there was only
there's been one study uh yeah
at around 8 000 people and the
conclusion was that only eight percent
actually subscribe to this narrative and
your own
media and education well you can imagine
you can hypothesize that
the political
if you consider political affiliation
unidimensional it's not clear that you
should
make a normal distribution
you can assume that the extremes are
rare
and yeah then of course
the question is how do you define what
constitutes extreme but it does appear
that a reasonable estimate on both the
right and the left is something
approximating five to eight percent and
in that same study
even the people who were identified as
relatively extreme in relationship to
their left-wing identity politics
position of 40 of them have also agreed
with the idea that
political correctness has gone too far
yeah so this identity narrative is
basically
it's it has consolidated its position in
the universities and in media yeah and i
would say
in human resources departments in large
corporations as well and i wouldn't
underestimate the danger of that
that's the new fifth column inside the
capitalist system itself welcomed by the
capitalists who want to have it both
ways
you have to give the identitarians some
their due credit because
if their if their doctrine is indeed as
intellectually weak as as it appears to
us
they've accomplished quite a lot with it
yes well continual subsidies for 40
years hasn't hurt you know what they've
managed to do is blur the distinction
between education and
indoctrination and it's easy to blur
that distinction because
you would hope that to some degree
what people you learn in university can
be transposed into action
yeah now and so drawing a
distinction between education and
indoctrination is very difficult thing
um but it still needs to be done i've
recommended to politicians in canada and
the us mostly in canada so far that
they
asked the universities
to generate in ontario my home province
the newly elected conservative
government has required the universities
and colleges to formulate a statement
a free speech policy statement and all
of the colleges in
ontario have now complied
and most of them have adopted some
variant of the chicago university of
chicago statement which is a real move
forward
and i've been thinking that an equally
useful thing to do would be to ask
colleges and universities to
formulate policy dissociating
education from indoctrination and there
is precedent for this that's
non-partisan
so for the canadian revenue agency which
is equivalent to the irs and the us
tax agency
forbids charities from engaging in
political activism
and so that means there's already a set
of definitions
regarding what constitutes activism say
rather than charitable work which seems
to me to be something that could be
usefully applied in the education field
distinguishing activism from education
because the problem is is that part of
the problem is that there is this small
minority of very destructive people in
my estimation
who have been subsidized for their
destructive work for about 50 years
and that's given them a power that's far
out of proportion to their
intellectual rigor to the credibility of
their ideas and to their numerical
prevalence
yeah
makes sense
and i think that the way to defeat this
is to embody the
the male archetype or
by either uh men or women doesn't really
matter so i think we can go through that
to our third point yeah well we could we
could just make us well let's just make
a side move quickly because
well so one of the things that's
happened in hungary for example
the president has cut funding if i
remember correctly to women's studies
and i know that in brazil there's no
pressure being placed now i don't know
this very well so this is vague on my
part but there's pressure being placed
on lgbt activist groups and so you could
say that one way of dealing with
the
unfortunate
and
unreasonable subsidization of this
particular political viewpoint would be
to stop
funding that at the university or public
level but the problem with that is it
opens up the specter of direct
government interference with the
autonomy of universities and that seems
to be a bad long-term plan so so then we
can go to the other topic which is i
think the way that you undermine a bad
story no undermine isn't right
i think the way that you
engage in proper
discourse in relationship to a weak set
of ideological presuppositions is by
formulating and communicating a better
story yeah so the better story to win
and that's a bit
that's a better transition well
hopefully well and hopefully it's
accurate hopefully it's the right way of
going about it
the person who tells the best story wins
and that that that echoes back to
weinstein's caution that the purpose of
the safe spaces which are clearly the
purpose of the space please is clearly
not to produce more resilient
individuals jonathan hype and um
his co-author
uh
they just finished the calling of the
american mind they just published that
lucianus
lay out the evidence that the safe space
doctrine actually weakens individuals
very clearly and i think any reasonable
psychologist or psychiatrist who knows
the literature on
exposure to anxiety-provoking stimuli
would have to agree that protecting
people from any exposure to things that
they're afraid of or contentious of is
like little to weaken them rather than
to strengthen them so i think it is to
protect the narrative
and
but i think the best way to combat a
pathological narrative is with a better
story yeah
i agree
and talking about better stories i think
i would now like to discuss one of the
best stories i've seen in modern cinema
and i'm talking about the movie
gladiator it came out in 2000 starting
russell crowe and jacqueline phoenix you
told me you saw it last night
yeah i hadn't watched it before so i
knew we were going to talk about it so i
thought yeah
i i was very surprised by that
i was very surprised by that
i don't know how i avoided it um
yeah
now and then there's a movie of
substantial cultural significance that
you just missed and that was what i
missed so yeah yeah well
you made up for it um so gladiator i
think this movie is
ingrained in the psyche of my generation
more so than any other
like epic epic movie of its of its sort
so there's other characters there's
there's aragorn from lord of the rings
there's hector from troy there's william
wallace from braveheart there's
spartacus there's leonidas from 300.
all these characters are the same
archetypal figures
but somehow only maximus decimus
meridius really strix it really sticks
through the years
and i have uh i've i've put some thought
into this and i
have some ideas about why particularly
this character and this movie uh
sticks i want to present you three
points that culminate in what i think is
the implicit central thesis that runs
throughout the movie so i'm going to
list now the three points and then the
central thesis
point number one is that maximus is by
far
the best modern portrayal of the male
archetype
um so he's highly capable but very
gentle and he's modest in word and body
language and he's admired in love solely
for his character and skill so that's
the secretary of the archetype point two
is that the movie also
contains the very best modern portrayal
of the embedded villain whose character
and skill are simply insufficient and he
makes up for it through deceit and
cruelness while still knowing every step
of the way that eventually he'll lose
there's nothing he can do about it
and three
the characters themselves are are
exquisite in their own right but in this
movie they're juxtapositioned within a
hostile brother framework
which makes it
which is a deeply archetypal framework
which might be the reason that it it
sticks so much more than all the other
architectural figures and this brings me
to the central thesis and i'm i only
figured this out two days ago and i'm
very excited to get to share this with
you
i think the central implicit thesis
throughout the whole movie is as follows
that no matter how powerful someone is
the pain of a man whose soul who has
been irreversibly corrupted
far out exceeds the pain of a righteous
man whose wife and son have been
murdered and who has been reduced to
abject slavery
which is really something to think about
yeah
right
yeah well they okay so the themes that
you've been developing there well okay
so the first thing we might also note
though that you um
lost over maybe that's the right way of
thinking about it is that
maximus is
a paragon of
soldierly virtue right he's a physical
combatant a warrior yeah he's dutiful
he serves his
commander but also serves the principles
more importantly the principles that
govern his command
and he serves the principles more than
the commander himself
and you can tell that because he chooses
not to serve the new emperor commodus
yeah because he doesn't believe that he
abides by the proper principles and
commodus of course also killed his own
father which means that he killed
the principles by which the state
um
he's like he's like the elder gods in
the mesopotamian creation myth who kill
absu who's their father and then try to
live on his corpse
it doesn't work out well for them all
that does is breed chaos and that's
exactly what happens in
in in the movie gladiator as well yeah
um
and
maximus as sun is an interesting son
is also an interesting character because
he becomes son as a consequence of his
virtue rather than as a consequence of
his birth right commodus has the
has the advantage of birth but
maximus has the advantage of virtue but
it's virtue it's a virtue of strength
and
um
you know that makes the movie in some
sense
also extremely barbaric there's just
endless death and killing which is a
very strange thing
when you're talking about someone who's
operating within a fundamentally moral
framework
and i guess part of the moral of the
story is that it's better to be a
soldier than a coward
and that's a
you know that's
it's not
i would say that on the one hand that's
self-evident and on the other hand
that's a mystery
because the coward might be able to
avoid the mayhem and killing that
characterizes the life of the soldier
anyways maximus does organize himself
under the
virtues of
courage and
and forbearance and strength
yeah so so my observation is actually of
course he's a very powerful soldier but
my observation is that that is not the
reason
not so much the reason this archetype
sticks
how i read this character that he is
the absolute embodiment of the
characteristics that allow you to
content with tragedy and malevolence in
an optimal way
not just on the battlefield it's not
really about the battlefield right well
you see you see his soldierly
capability as a representation of
competence itself yeah
guided by principle yeah i think that's
reasonable
and i also think that that's probably
how the conduct of the soldiers should
be judged right
yeah it appears that
soldiers are necessary despite the
mayhem that
warfare produces
yeah we haven't figured out how to
dispense with
that
necessity
so do you think sorry do you think the
canaan the do you think that the canaan
able framework in which it is implicitly
uh structured do you think that adds to
to how much a story sticks yes
definitely like
why is that
well because the story of cain and abel
does lay out
very very elegantly and and
with incredible compression
two fundamentally opposed modes of being
the both being that characterizes able
the favored son and the motive being
that characterizes cain
and abel is
competent and virtuous
and god-fearing let's say but more
practically
which means he's allied with the highest
of principles that that's the right way
to think about it psychologically
whatever the that height the highest of
principles might be
there's an attempt one of the things
that you might
consider
psychologically is that
the movement from polytheism
to monotheism
parallels
parallels the integration of the
individual psyche and
the development of larger and larger
scale social organizations all those
things happen at the same time so you
imagine that
the larger scale the organization
the human organization so the more
people included under the umbrella of
the same state the more organized and
orderly the principles by which that
state have to function must be
because of the increasing complexity and
also the
the
problem of having to determine
how the state can remain intact over a
long period of time without fragment
so the state has to organize itself so
that
the needs and wants of the bulk of the
population are met with sufficient
regularity so that the state itself
doesn't fragment
and that means that the state has to
organize itself
in what you might regard as
a virtuous manner that can be iterated
and at the same time the people who
compose the state in its increasing
complexity have to ally themselves with
that long-term state goal
so i'd say it's a it's a coalition
between psychological integration and
sociological complexity and and that's
that is
foreshadowed we might say or accompanied
by the movement from polytheism which is
the pulling of people in all directions
by fundamental motivation and natural
forces into monotheism which is the
direction of the individual
under the rubric of a single set of
principles a single superordinate set of
principles now what those principles are
is not obvious which is partly why we're
having the discussion of gladiator
so i can give you an example of this so
for example
in the old testament
you see
the articulation of the guiding
principles emerge in its most
fully formed
manner with the commandments of moses
so you might say
all of the diverse forces that might
people people hither and yawn have been
aggregated into a list of thou shalt not
here's how to regulate yourself here's
how to inhibit yourself across time so
that you can have a stable long-term
large-scale society
but then there's a mystery that emerges
in the new testament which is
it emerges for example when christ is
asked by the scribes and pharisees which
is the greatest of the commandments
and christ
actually performs a very intelligent
sleight of hand and he says well
you have to love god with all your heart
and all your soul and you have to love
your brother as if he's yourself love
your neighbor as if he's yourself on on
those propositions rest all the
commandments and the law there's an
attempt to integrate
even the commandments into something
that's a higher order principle and that
higher order principle actually
manifests itself in judeo-christian
society as the logos whatever that is
and it's something like
truthful communication
devoted towards the highest good
and and the embodiment of that becomes
the fundamental principle and in
gladiator you see
movement towards that embodiment right
because maximus is
an organized and disciplined person
who's governed by principle the question
is and the question is posed throughout
the movie well what is rome
right that's asked four or five times
it's asked by marcus aurelius because he
feels that a lot of what he's done is a
failure it's asked by commodus and it's
asked by the sister
uh who's whose name escapes me at the
moment
it's what i think it's lucina
okay okay okay
and they all ask well what is wrong but
she comes the closest she says it's a
great idea
but it's not it's an animating principle
and the question is what is the
animating principle now whatever it is
maximus embodies it far more than
commodus and maximus is a able figure
e-a-b-e-l whereas
or comedus is
clearly a figure of of cain
yeah
he makes improper sacrifices and they're
never well regarded he says constantly
you know that he all he ever did was try
to please his father yeah
well his sacrifices went
unappreciated and that's what made him
bitter and resentful and murderous and
and doomed to a catastrophic death and a
figure of great evil and a tyrant and
all of that
so yes it's got a fundamentally
archetypal structure
yeah so who do you this is like a
compressed version of the thesis
who do you think suffers more in this
story is is it communists or mexicans
well it's the same question that that
solzhenitsyn posed in the gulu like
archipelago to some degree it's like
do you do you want to lose your life
what's worse to put your life at risk
let's say or to put everything you love
at risk or to lose your conscience
and solzhenitsyn's conclusion was that
there's no suffering greater than that
which accompanies loss of conscience
that's hell
and there well there's something very
very profound about that because one of
the things i've just been writing about
this interestingly enough
um
it was the prophet elijah
who's who first seems to have
it's in the story of the prophet of the
prophet elijah as far as i can tell
where there's the first intimation that
god
might speak to human beings not as the
external force of natural power
storms fire wind
winter
earthquakes
all the all the overwhelming
natural forces that human beings were
subject to
or maybe even
not as
internal forces that would more
characterize some of the other
polytheistic gods like lust or rage or
or terror
but as the voice of conscience itself
which which is
which is
described in in
one king's which is this contains the
story of elijah as the still small voice
that's the first time that that phrase
emerges and so it's the idea that
there's something that
as a psychological factor conscience
itself that calls to you that that has a
dialogue with you even more importantly
because it's conscience doesn't tell you
what to do
it hints at what you shouldn't do right
and it isn't a deterministic force it's
not like when your conscience grips you
you're forced to act in a manner that's
in accordance with your conscience you
can choose to violate it and so there's
this idea that
god
transforms himself or becomes known as
the voice of conscience and that that's
the link between human beings and
divinity itself i actually think this is
a highly credible hypothesis and let's
say that
well you need a powerful sustaining
meaning to keep you from the bitterness
of cain
and that's to be found in the
relationship with something of divine
significance
well maybe that's mediated through your
conscience
and this relationship is absent within
kane so he has severed his relationship
with consciousness and that's why not
with consciousness but with conscience
conscience
yeah again right with conscience yeah
well that's right because
conscience is
imagine that conscience is the
manifestation of the instinct for good
and evil
yeah it's what now so so we can take the
argument apart a little bit
a lot of what makes people bitter
is that they feel that there is wrong in
the world it might be a large scale
society is unfair the natural world is a
catastrophe human beings are
intrinsically malevolent
the the the structure of being itself is
wrong in some moral sense okay but
that's interesting because they wouldn't
be bothered by that if they didn't have
some sense of morality itself
well that what that means is that
conscience even the conscience that's
driving them towards their cynicism
is the dawning of the realization of a
moral dimension to life
now
conscience doesn't seem to manifest
itself as an omniscient force that
cannot be
denied it's more something that
beckons and harkens and also something
that you need to enter into a
negotiation with but interestingly
enough in the old testament even before
the transformation of god let's say into
the voice of conscience you have
continual intimations that whatever
yahweh is
is something that can be negotiated with
so for example abraham negotiates with
yahweh
when he tries to save the inhabitants of
sodom from being decimated by god's
wrath
he bargains he says well if i can find
50 good men will you spare the city and
god says yes well if i can find 20 if i
can find 10 if i can find a single good
man and god
strangely enough despite his omniscience
agrees
this bargain and so so god even in the
old testament i mean the old testament
god is often hillaried as a very
intransigent and tyrannical being but
it's clear even in the earlier stories
that he can be negotiated with oddly
enough then you see the same thing with
jacob who eventually becomes israel
right and israel means he who wrestles
with god which is a very very
interesting idea right is that
if god can be assimilated to conscience
then what that means is that the true
followers of god are those who wrestle
with their conscience and jacob before
he's transformed into israel jacob's a
trickster figure
right he's a he's a maneuver he's a
salesman he's uh he's someone who's not
above using trickery to gain his end
because he cheats his brother for
example out of his birthright and then
is subject to the same treatment at the
hands of his uncle but in any case he's
not classically moral person
but he wrestles with the angel on the
banks of the river when he returns to
see the brother that he's betrayed and
he wrestles all night with
an angel who also turns out to be god
who puts his hip out of joint it's a
very contentious battle and he actually
defeats the angel who is god and
requires him to bless him in the morning
and the blessing is that jacob will now
be called israel and that's he who
wrestles successfully with god it's an
unbelievably interesting sequence of
ideas because
it also speaks i think to something
approximating human destiny it's like
well what's the purpose of man
with god or in god's absence almost say
forget god's absence for a moment but
assuming god what's the purpose of man
given that god is omniscient and of the
present
and and
and uh
um
omnipotent
what's the purpose of man and it looks
like the
fundamental idea that's emerging as
monotheism emerges in the west is that
god and man enter into a partnership
to co-create the world it's something
like that and that you do that under the
guidance of your conscience so the
destiny of man would be to transcend in
dialogue with god symbolically speaking
yes and to overcome suffering to the
degree that that can be managed and to
overcome malevolence to the degree that
that can be managed and to do that in
dialogue with god that's that's the idea
that emerges that's the great
monotheistic idea and the thing that
it's sort of a continuation let's say of
the argument i was making with laying
out with you before about responsibility
and meaning it's like well let's let's
assume
that you find meaning and responsibility
and that you need a meeting that will
sustain you through suffering and
malevolence it's like where is that to
be found well let's say it's to be found
in hearkening to the clarion call of
conscience
it could easily i can't see how that's
wrong
maybe if you can also reverse engineer
it that if you take commodus as a test
case that when you sever the
relationship between the individual
the individual and conscience
then suffering is maximized well look
what well look he's he suffers terribly
because yeah he's isolated from everyone
but the thing he suffers most from
is the fact that he's alienated from his
father
right and that that torments him
terribly and that's actually why he
hates maximus so much which is also a
retelling of the king and naval story is
because maximus
for all the terrible things that's
happened to him he's never severed from
the father
yeah
and and that's the thing comedis cannot
tolerate
and i do think that his suffering
exceeds that of maximus yeah probably
because it's so pointless
and it's it's to me it's such a striking
and interesting idea that
that that to be corrupt
entails more suffering than to be the
victim of corruption if you are
righteous if you're a righteous victim
right right
it feels so profound and not not
not that intuitively true because
maximus he loses everything his wife and
son are murdered he's a slave so it's
not
it's not
right whereas
is emperor yeah so it's not at face
value obvious that maximus
suffers less than commodus
right i agree it seems
but it seems to be the thesis running
throughout the theme
well it's it's it's perhaps
the only reason that
maximus suffers less to some degree is
that
the fact that he's maintained his virtue
makes this
suffering bearable
yeah and you see that as well when he
has the argument with with the man who
comes to own him the former gladiator
at the end decides to do the honorable
thing and to smuggle
maximus out of the out of the prison
he also decides to
to
take the path of virtue let's say that
in some sense gives a transcendent
meaning to his life yeah it redeems him
because he was he was also he was also
miserable
right
right and and so but the redemption that
interesting there too the redemption
comes at the cost of his own death and
there's a very interesting
archetypal theme there as well because
it is see
what happens is monotheism develops in
the west let's say
as it culminates
at least along the christian line of
thinking in the figure of christ is that
the
principle that becomes the highest ideal
is
the
is the mode of being that takes
suffering voluntarily onto itself as its
full responsibility right that's the
acceptance of the
crucifixion and the betrayal that goes
along with it so
you know christ faces satan in the
desert so that's the confrontation with
malevolence and he accepts the necessity
of his own violent death so that's
natural that's the that's the terrible
power of nature manifested in death and
the terrible power of society manifested
in the ability to punish so he faces all
of those things voluntarily
and the
the
psychological process that
enables that in some sense or that
transcends it is the death and rebirth
it's
rebirth
and to be redeemed
means to allow yourself to die when
necessary see that's what happens with
the with the with the gladiator uh the
head gladiators he allows himself to die
when necessary now he dies a physical
death but there's
but there's metaphysical deaths that can
be
undertaken continually it's a spiritual
death it's like if you encounter
if you find yourself entangled in
corruption
and you need to set yourself right
as a consequence what that means is that
you have to sacrifice
some of yourself
the erroneous part of yourself and so
the idea is that you can
you can die and be reborn in a spiritual
sense that's what baptism is for example
and that that's what redeeds you is the
identification with that part of you
that will die and be reborn in the
furtherance and pursuit of a higher
order principle
yeah
i think that's what the holy ghost means
i think i think that's what the idea of
the holy ghost means as far as i can
tell it's something like that
let me just see what what would be the
best transition
um
because we have two more topics which
we're talking about art is the next
thing
yeah you wanted to reverse the last two
so we still have individual
individuation
well let's start with art
look i mean
i was looking for example at a painting
last night which was raphael's
transfiguration of christ and it's this
so the transfiguration occurs when
christ goes up on the mountain with his
disciples i think it's peter james and
john
and on the mountain
he meets moses so bearer of the mosaic
law and he meets elijah and elijah is
the prophet who encounters the still
small voice
and he's transfigured his face shines
his clothing is is
is is what lightened to an unbearable
sunlight whiteness and
it's it's too much for the disciples to
tolerate to see all this
and so
so that's his transfiguration then when
he comes down from the mountaintop this
is all portrayed in this painting of
raphael so you see the transfiguration
at the top and you see the second part
of the story at the boy he comes down
and he casts a demon out of a young man
and i thought well that's unbelievably
apropos because
you know while you're smiling because
you can see why it's apropos at least to
some degree it's like
i think that
we all have the proclivity to be
possessed to a greater or lesser degree
by
the modern equivalent of of demons and
that's ideological possession or
possession by cynicism possession by
that cynicism that characterizes cain
are possession by nihilism or these
totalitarian
ideologies
and the question is well how are those
cast out
and the answer is and this is portrayed
in the painting it's portrayed in the
story strange story of christ's
transfiguration and its association with
moses and elijah unbelievably complex
narrative
structures right pointing at something
that
was not fully articulated but that's
intuited by the storytellers and the
artists that
the
willingness to die and be reborn in the
service of the highest principle is in
fact the
process by which
possession is
eradicated
and and that's an idea that
that idea is so
overwhelmingly complicated and
sophisticated that it has to be dreamed
up and it has to be represented
artistically before it can be
comprehended you know the painting by
raphael the one i'm describing that was
regarded as the
greatest oil painting in the world for
300 years
it's a non-trivial piece of art like i
think it was painted let me just let me
just check this because i might as well
get the date right
um
it was it's a renaissance painted rafael
[Music]
transfiguration
i'm looking again look at that so it's
okay 15 20. so from 1520 to 1820 that
was regarded as the greatest oil
painting in the world that's three
centuries that's you gotta you gotta
think about it i gotta think when
something like that happens it's like
what's being represented there well i
think it's what's being represented is
something akin to what i've just been
discussing and that's a good example of
how the artists the storytellers
and and the and the image makers
are
laid the pathway for articulated
representations you see the same thing
happening in gladiator right because
it's a story but but there's a moral to
the story and there's a pointer towards
an articulated set of principles
potentially articulated set of
principles
so the idea you just let out you think
that it had to be
it had to manifest itself in a dream or
story
version before it could be articulated
like in an operational way
yeah because the ideas have to so look
the way i look at it is this way first
of all to some degree
these ideas are encoded in behavior
so for example in exodus moses received
the law
but remember before he received the law
he's wandering around in the desert for
a long time
so it's in chaos with with a group of
extraordinarily fractious israelites who
are constantly fighting amongst
themselves and who are constantly
tempted to worship other idols
so in in a chaotic state
then
the temptation of
principles re
manifests itself what principles should
be guiding us and that's portrayed in
the exit of the story as the proclivity
to chase after false violence now the
israelites actually come to moses for a
very long period of time in pairs or in
families to adjudicate disputes
and so he does that to the point of
exhaustion this is prior to receiving
the ten commandments and so what's what
happens with the ten commandments is
it's as if
moses
comes to realize through revelation
he comes to realize in an articulated
manner the principles that the
israelites are already to some degree
implicitly guided by that actually
produce peace and harmony
their behavioral patterns but no one
knows what they are because they're not
conscious enough they haven't mapped
themselves enough so the mosaic
revelation is part of that process of
mapping and the mapping itself is
represented in the story of moses and
within the story of moses is actually
contained the articulated virtues the
commandments let's say
but that's only part of the process of
the unfolding of the virtue
it still doesn't answer the question
which is the question that's eventually
posed to christ it's like well that's
all well and good but what's the highest
virtue
well that's that's an
insanely complicated question because
it's no different than well how should
you conduct your life right it's the
hardest of questions
and so
we've had to gather as a collective
we've had to gather information about
well what is it what does it look like
with someone when a particular person
lives an undesirable life
we tell the story of someone who lives
an undesirable life or maybe he tells
his own story and then we aggregate a
hundred stories of undesirable life and
then we abstract out from those stories
what constitutes undesirable and so
that's like a picture of cain right it's
a portrait of cain
and we do the same thing on the other
side we listen to people who who have
lived triumphantly
and we aggregate their stories and we
synthesize and we say well then we we
extract from that a portrait of abel and
that's a precursor
like
the successful and the unsuccessful are
precursors to
abel and cave and abel and cain are
precursors to the divine figures the
quasi-divine figures are the divine
figures of christ and satan right it's
it's an abstract process of continual
abstraction and that's all done through
at least to begin with through ritual
and narrative and art
it's so complicated it can't be done any
other way
so first it's acted out then it enters
the domain of ritual art and and
narratives yes then it's then it becomes
operational like an operation and then
those things loop right because once you
get the image sure well once you get the
image in the ritual the drama then those
modes of communication start to alter
behavior
yeah you know so it's like well that's
why we're having this discussion we're
talking about gladiator we're talking
about a movie that's an artistic
representation and we're discussing it
to articulate principles and we're also
articulating those principles so that in
principle our behavior could be altered
yeah that's exactly i never thought
about the loop oh yes you have to think
about the loop these things these things
feed back
right so to be it's it's the collective
behavior it's that negotiation at the
collective
level that fractious
centuries long lenny along negotiation
that produces something like uh
synthesis
yeah and that synthesis is represented
in in drama and mythology and ritual and
art and then that's articulating but
those loot
and so the whole process starts to
spiral up
yeah maybe a spiral upward at an
increasingly rapid rate yeah so what
about what what i was always wondering
is that if these archetypal patterns
that lead to the most
favorable life are already known for
such a long time why does any every
generation seem to have to invent them
in you there's there's no known like one
of the things that plato
the socrates insisted on was that all
learning was remembering
okay so let's say that when you're born
you you have a proclivity to manifest a
number of patterns and and you certainly
do you can manifest the patterns of rage
and
and fear and hunger and thirst
like
but
but then also imagine okay so it's
something like this
as this looping process has occurred
the people who are more likely to
manifest the pattern that is being
pointed to
are more practically likely to live
and to
successfully
propagate
so there's an evolutionary element that
kicks in right now so if the society
values something
and the degree to which you manifest
that value is proportionate to your
success yeah and your success is
proportionate to your reproductive
fitness
then as
then over time
the proclivity for that sort of ethical
behavior will become
coded in some sense in
your genetic structure
being selected for for that yeah so then
you might say well that exists this is
this is what the archetype is in some
sense
it exists as
the possibility of being gripped by a
particular kind of vision now there
might be enough diversity in the ideal
so that you can't emerge from the womb
let's say fully christian
you know you know what i mean put it
that way
yeah
but but that doesn't mean that there
won't be something that beckons to you
as a consequence of observing the
manifestation of a kind of ideal and
that doesn't make it to you because
otherwise you wouldn't be gripped by the
damn stories
yeah but but here's the rub too
it can't be
hard coded exactly
so look
here's here's something interesting
about
christianity
it was actually posed as an interesting
question in
in the musical jesus christ superstar
near the end
um the
the actor who played judas
asks christ after he's dead there's sort
of a
there's a scene where everyone's
singing and dancing it's a strange sort
of quasi-disco scene and
judas asks why christ had to come to
earth at such a strange time and in such
an isolated place
because he appears as a carpenter in a
backwoods region you know two thousand
years ago why then why there and that
answer is
that the divine principle
has to manifest itself constantly within
the confines of an individual life with
all of the peculiarities and
idiosyncrasies and limitations of that
individual life
and so part of the reason that
the ideal beckons is because
you can't just be born as christ
because what christ represents let's say
this overarching ideal is actually the
union of the divine with the particulars
of your time and place
and so because you're particularized
then
you have to determine how to manifest
the archetype in your conditions
in your specific conditions
that and that's partly associated with
that dialogue with your conscience so
there's an archetypal mode of being
that's that's supposedly ideal and you
have to integrate it with your
surroundings
that's what needs to happen
it has to be met that's right it has to
be manifest in the particulars of your
time and place that's the individuation
process yeah
that's exactly what it is because you
regard the self
like
you regarded christ as a symbol of the
self he actually reversed the the
spiritual and the psychological
yeah right or the theological and the
psychological and he thought he was
thinking about the cosmic christ as and
for young the self was the totality of
individual being it was
everything that you were right now
everything that you were in the past but
also everything that you could possibly
become across
your your set of potential futures
there's there's one paragraph from jung
that i'm going to send to you in the
chat right now
and i would like to ask you if you could
could read it out it's not that long
because i think that illustrates exactly
what you're talking about
i'm
[Music]
sending you a link
if you click on it it's an image and you
probably know it when a summit is
reached
when the bud unfolds
and from the lesser the greater emerges
and as nietzsche says one becomes two
and the greater figure which one always
was but which remained invisible appears
to the lesser personality with the force
of a revelation
yes and that's the manifestation of the
self that's right what that is is an
intimation of who you could be
yeah and it's it's also an intimation of
what you're associated with that might
guide you to what you could be so so it
would you might say it's a revelation of
your own possibility but it's your rev a
revelation of your possibility in
relationship to something that's
infinite and transcendent yeah that's
the that's the
and i would also say that that does that
is also
very commonly manifested by a
transformation in the relationship with
conscience because when something like
this happens sometimes this happens to
people for example in
hallucinatory or psychedelic experiences
right
they start to take their conscience
seriously
as the see you believed at least to some
degree that
what guided your interest and that would
include your conscience was a
manifestation of the totality of the
self in the
restricted domain of the present
okay so that's okay so
so okay
which one always was but which remained
invisible
right that's the heavenly father that
would be the the marcus aurelius
principle that manifests itself in in in
maximus and that that that communist
resists
and and which marcus aurelius also
made himself subordinate to at least to
some degree right that's the one which
always was but which remained invisible
yeah
he was truly and hopelessly little
will always drag the revelation of the
greater down to the level of his
littleness
and will never understand that the day
of judgment for his littleness has
dawned
but the man who is inwardly great will
know that the long expected friend of
his soul the immortal one has now really
come to lead captivity captive
that is to seize hold of him by whom
this immortal had always been confined
and held prisoner and to make his life
flow into that greater life
a moment of deadliest peril
nietzsche's prophetic vision of the
tightrope walker reveals the awful
danger that lies in having a tight rope
walking attitude towards an event to
which saint paul gave the most exalted
name he could find
yeah
that's uh that's quite the
that's quite the densely packed paradigm
that's that one
for for
reviews it's from it's from the
archetypes and the collective
unconscious right page 121
that's volume 1 right because volume 2
is ion which is even a more frightening
book so yes because the peril that you
talks about there is the peril of
psychosis at least in part inflation
because
the manifestation of that
that second figure let's say the self
it's it's a deadly temptation as well
because
once you
see that there's a relationship between
you and the transcendent let's say you
start to take that seriously
then you can
you can you can become inflated by that
sense of prophetic duty let's say and
and and that's
and that's a very dangerous
yeah
he actually writes this like 20 pages
further he says for the great psychic
danger which always is is always
connected with individuation
lies in the identification of ego
consciousness with the self this
produces inflation which threaten which
threatens conscience
consciousness with dissolution yes and
he wrote a great essay a great essay
called relations between the ego and the
unconscious
which is completely
incomprehensible unless you know the
background that we're discussing where
he warned very carefully that
you have to stay
in the proper relationship to the self
right if the self overtakes the the
the ego
then
that's a descent into like manic
religious insanity
yeah something that balance has to be
struck where there's a relationship with
the transcendent but there's also
still the grounding in the particulars
of here and now you see this echo this
idea echoed interestingly enough in the
superhero mythology that
dominated the adolescent imagination in
the 20th century every superhero so
imagine the superhero is like a partial
manifestation of the redemptive
archetype
every superhero has to have an alter ego
the alter ego well for superman it's
clark kent mild-mannered reporter and
for spider-man it's you know high school
troubled high school quasi nerd
and but but what's so interesting about
those stories is that they understand
that without the alter ego there's no
superhero
that both of those have to exist at the
same time the limitations
and the and the transcendence of the
limitations have to both be there that
that terrible paradoxical juxtaposition
yeah
and so because the the character isn't
the character can't exist without
that tension and
i think that that's well that motif
wouldn't recur continually unless there
was something to it that was
narratively
precise and accurate
there's something in this paragraph that
i want to tie together with our previous
thought because jung talks about
the end stage of individuation as as a
coming together with the immortal
because of the immortal now joseph
campbell campbell does exactly the same
he says the christ in you doesn't die
the christ in you survives death and
resurrects and you said in our last talk
when you
um closed your um
you elaborate you elaborated on the
death of socrates and how he died in
truth and honor and then you said that
part of the spirit doesn't die
so there is this theme of
these people are somehow
connected with something that is immoral
and and eternal
could that be understood simply as they
have
they have established a relation with an
archetypal mode of being that is eternal
and that continues to exist uh beyond
them and before them but they've they've
established a relationship with is that
what that what he means by
by the immortal well that yes that that
is that's what's meant is that that's
right it's that it's the eternal pattern
it's the eternal music it's like you're
dancing to the eternal music
and the music goes on even if you depart
the scene yeah exactly now the christian
there's a christian insistence though
that that i also wouldn't overlook which
is that
that also characterizes the finite
right that's the promise of the
resurrection that the resurrection of
the body is that the christians insist
that
that transcendent factor exists and and
that's the christ that's the word that's
there at the beginning of time and at
the end of time as as the judge in
revelation right this transcendent logos
that's
eternal
but that that's no
more valuable in some sense than the
particular the particularized creature
that's that's that's
subject to
apparent
apparent permanent death
and
you know it's very difficult for modern
people to
grant the idea of the bodily
resurrection any
credence and
i
it's not something of which anyone can
speak i believe with any degree of
what would you say
non-arrogant authority something like
that but
by the same token the world is a very
strange place and it isn't obvious to me
that
i've learned to
i've learned to be very
cautious in
casually dismissing
deep and ancient ideas regardless of
their strangeness
and i do think that see the thing that's
so interesting about that christian
insistence is that
it valorizes the particular
that's unbelievably important because
you could say well
if it's merely a matter of the eternal
then the particular doesn't matter but
then if the particular doesn't matter
you end up with that kind of nihilistic
buddhism
the suffering that characterizes or even
in in the proclivity for christianity to
degenerate into the forms that nietzsche
criticized which is well when you chase
everything out into an eternal beyond it
justifies everything terrible that's
happening on earth as trivial and
insignificant and relieves you of your
moral responsibility for for addressing
it
you can't
at the very minimum the idea that the
body is resurrected is a valorization of
the value of the particular here and now
and of the body and an emphasis on the
fact that that has divine value as well
it needs to be attended to and cared for
properly at minimum it's that yeah
it's profound
there's one one thing uh under young
paragraph i want to reflect on it's uh
when he says that individuation is a
could be a moment of deadliest peril and
then he refers to the to the tight rope
walker from zaradustra
what i think this means is that it can
be so
the danger can be so great when you
embark on individuation because it
it almost by definition means that that
the lesser you the lesser part of your
soul the lesser soul has to die yeah and
then and i think i've been there in my
own life and
that requires violence and recovery is
by no means guaranteed right that's
exactly well that's why that's why that
motif that's the motif of going into the
abyss to rip to to rescue your father
like it's an abyss
there's no guarantee that you'll emerge
from it
like it
it it's a real it's genuine peril now
the you know the the
the
what you need to be armed with in some
sense to face that is
the willingness to die
the faith in rebirth
the the
the
what the the willingness as well or or
the the decision to start to abide by
the truth
because in a moment of great peril this
is another thing that that this is one
of the things i think that terrified me
into um
attempting to abide by the truth to the
degree that i've been able to manage
this see i i started to understand not
least by reading jung that there would
come points in my life where i needed to
rely on my own judgment
that i would be in a particular
situation that no one could advise me
about because no one would have access
to the information about the
particularities of my situation that i
would have and that i could call on
my relationship with the eternal let's
say to some degree but
if i had warped and corrupted my own
judgment
then
when when the necessity for a decision
emerged i would make the wrong decision
yeah and then i'd be lost
what stood out to me the few times you
talked about this
in a few lectures like as a sidetrack
you talked about the death of the soul
and what what stood out to me is that
you did this in a very
very visceral way you really felt
it seemed to me like you felt the
gravity of it
and then when you uh kind of laid out
your own story that you had to stop
drinking and stop smoking to to um to
focus more on your work
intuitively there was it was a kind of a
disparity between how visceral you could
talk about the death of the soul
and what you described as what that
meant for you which i interpreted as
mainly changing your lifestyle a little
and
and focus on your studies
so the question would be that
why why do you think i i saw that
disparity and and if the disparity is
indeed there
how is it that you can talk about the
death of the soul with such figure
well i think
i i do think that there are things that
are worse than death
i mean i think that psychological
disintegration might be worse than death
because it can go on for so long and and
it can be so incredibly painful
i do think that your point about
communist communists is correct is that
the state that he exists in is worse
than death
it's hell
and now the disparity i'm not sure
exactly what you meant by that
um yeah
and what i meant with is that you talk
with such vigor and in such a visceral
way about the death of the soul
and then
when you talked about letting parts of
yourself die
you said it was mainly
it was stopped drinking stopping and
stop smoking
it was your responsibility i would say
at least to some degree it was is the
letting go of that because
i had to make a choice between
something approximating
gratifying immediate pleasure-seeking
and hyper-social a hyper-social way of
being
you know that wasn't sustainable in many
ways for obvious reasons and
doing
the difficult intellectual work
that i had decided to embark on and that
was a that's a death of a previous
personality and it is trivial in some
sense because it's
it's
it's burning off that which obviously
needs to be burned off but i would also
say by the same token that that doesn't
make it a straightforward process
you alluded to this you know you said
that you underwent a similar set of
experiences where
the old parts of you had to die it's
like well that's
sub optimal and immature as they are
first of all
those are still parts that are alive and
still
and still an element of your being
they might even be parts that you love
and that other people love yeah and and
there's certainly things that you're
familiar with their their modes of being
that you're familiar with it's
it's a major sacrifice to let elements
of your personality go it's it's also a
proper sacrifice
it was not an indictment on your
apartment
no no i understand that good good see
the problem with the identity politics
types as far as i'm concerned is that
their
proclivity is always to sacrifice
someone else
the oppressor
and it's always externalized the
oppressor
but in the individuation process
you're the oppressor
you are the oppressor
and it's much see and this is also the
problem this is something i really came
to understand when i was writing the
forward for the new version of social
media and school live archipelago
because what's the problem here well
something has to be sacrificed to put
the world right
well who what who or what is going to be
sacrificed but you better make the
proper sacrifices or you won't establish
the right relationship with the
transcendent well let's identify the
evil as something external to us and
sacrifice that well what does that mean
well what it meant in the russian
revolution was that everyone died
but more specifically everyone was
killed
they were made into a burnt offering
to god and it was inappropriate it's
like well if you're going to sacrifice
because you have to you sacrifice
yourself
right that's the crop that's the that's
the that's the crucifixion metaphor
and what you sacrifice is you allow
those parts of you that are unworthy to
die
you encourage them to die even
and and but we don't want to be foolish
and say that that's merely a matter of
pursuing your bliss let's say in in the
in the joseph campbell manner or in the
maybe in the satirical
uh
[Music]
i mean that's being a bit hard on
campbell but it was an unfortunate
phrase
yeah because it it and he knew better
because he knew about the journey into
the abyss
yeah the sacrifice is
even if it's partial it's still a death
i think also that this is why
the death and rebirth rebirth theme
resonates so so immediately in in in
popular culture and in literature for
example gandalf who who fell into the
underworld yeah he
fought the bell rock and then emerged as
again of the white right and everyone's
everyone's soul well and that's like
that's a that's a re-representation of
the transfiguration of moses and christ
gandalf the white
so and it's not like tolkien didn't know
these things
he he knew these things perfectly well
that's right in such a relief i remember
when i was a kid reading the lord of the
rings for the first time i was so
appalled when gandalf disappeared and so
relieved what he made when he
was like oh no gandalf's gone like it's
the death of god right what what are we
going to do with the great wizard
has disappeared
yeah yeah and it is a terrible trial and
you see that with gandalf's experiences
in underworld and
he comes out white well it's funny it
comes out white white's interesting
because white is the sun and white is
purity but white is also age
you know and and to undergo those
experiences is also to risk
while the physiological the
psychophysiological stress that that
whitens your beard and that that grays
your hair
i'm going to tweet out now jordan
peterson says white is purity
yeah you're tellish man now but the
thing is you also see this in more
shallow popular culture have you ever
heard of dragon ball z
no it's it's kind of it was a cartoon
it's an in anime
and uh
these creatures they're called saiyans
and whenever they're they're warriors
and whenever they're in a fight with
some eternal enemy
and the moment they're about to die
they can't their their spirit and their
body can't take any more
they become super saiyans this which is
they resurrect and they transcend and
their hair stands up and it turns turns
it turns yellow and they get electricity
all around them so whenever they are
about to die
that's when they transcend so they have
been completely destroyed and that's
when their transcendence
occurs and that in the beginning they
can't control it
and that's the theme that keeps the
entire saga together is this continual
transcendence of the of the figures one
of the themes that i developed in maps
of meaning is that there's ways of
construing yourself like you construe
yourself as who you are
that's a stable state let's say who you
are right now that's me
and then that all falls apart
and then you construe yourself as the
chaos that that is ensues when
everything falls apart and that's a
state of hopelessness and nihilism
and then maybe you recover from that and
you establish a new sense of order
yeah you say well i passed through the
underworld and now i'm in a better place
and this is me this better place
but then it's subject to fragmentation
as well and so what you learn is that
you're not the
order
no matter how
compelling and secure and promising that
order is and you're not the chaos that
ensues when that order is fragmented and
you're not even the re-establishment of
new order you're the process by which
that transformation continually occurs
and that is the process of death and
rebirth and that's what you identify
with is that
ever renewing process of death and
rebirth and that's the identification
with christ that the christians that the
christian narrative is aiming at
instilling
aiming
to the degree that something like that
aims
yeah
so is this also the the rope nietzsche
refers to that man is a road between
beast and over man
i know that's not exactly the christian
delineation but it's still there i think
that's more i think that's probably more
associated with the idea that we were
talking about earlier i mean these ideas
are all linked but i think that's more
associated with the idea that
of the partnership between
man and god mediated by conscience
yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah man is that
is that intermediary thing just an
intermediary figure because we're we're
moving towards the idea but we're
clearly not that
yeah and that is a tightrope place
because moving towards the ideal is
precarious right because you're not the
ideal and you can tumble at any moment
yeah and so there is a precariousness to
our being
psychically
psychologically and spiritually as well
as physically
it's well that's that's part of of the
eternal crucifixion as well is that that
constant vulnerability of being
and it's part of the burden of being
human
yeah but the necessary burden i suppose
me in my more
i don't know what would you call them
i don't know you have these moments of
thinking where
you they're more metaphysical in my more
metaphysical moments i suppose then i do
see that
god and man are engaged in a partnership
to bring about the kingdom of god on
earth something like that that there's
something about that story that's
exactly right that we should be
struggling uphill with our burdens
towards the highest possible ideal and
that there's something about that that's
true
or at least it's more true than anything
else we can conceive of
yeah and so that's the great adventure
of life that's what you want to be
called to and i think you are called to
that by your conscience
yeah
i think
we've uh we we've talked for about 90
minutes now i think this is a very good
time yeah yeah this is a
great note to close off on